pour l'ump élu la semaine dernière dans
le canton gatineau en bourgogne jean
baptiste lemoyne en direct d'auxerre
bonsoir d'abord peut-être pour cette
élection d'un binôme fn au conseil
départemental de l'yonne écoutez nous
n'avions pas ménager notre peine pour
faire en sorte que des candidats
locaux enraciné puissent triompher en
tous les cas ça avait été le sens du
message que nous avions été plusieurs à
adresser bon manifestement localement
les circonstances ont conduit à un
résultat différent mais moi ce que je
veux voir dans le résultat de cette
élection c'est quand même la victoire
massive de nombreux candidats de
renouveau ou associé à un certain nombre
de gens qui ont une grande expertise ici
au conseil général et qui l'emportent
vous l'avais dit dans dans 17 cantons et
moi je veux saluer la victoire de
grégory dorte et dominique sino à
pont-sur-yonne combat très difficile
mais également valérie le g michel
ducroux à auxerre c'est pas rien xavier
courtois et sonia pas touré sur un
vallon notamment et bien d'autres encore
donc ce résultat est un succès mais
c'est pas un chèque en blanc
parce qu on a tous entendu en faisant
campagne une certaine exaspération un
certain ras-le-bol de la part des
artisans des commerçants des retraités
est donc maintenant il faut que nous
soyons les uns et les autres au rendez
vous des résultats 1
il ya vraiment comment dire une perte de
crédit c'est triste à dire mais de du
politique est donc maintenant et bien
tous les conseillers départementaux qui
qui sommes élus nous devons faire en
sorte et vient d'être exemplaire de
fixer un cap clair
et puis de répondre aux urgences il ya
des urgences en matière d'économie
locale en matière de numérique en
matière d'accès aux soins
c'est pour cela que moi je plaide pour
vraiment la mise en place d'une sorte d'
équipe de france de l'yonne parce qu'il
faut qu'on aille marquer des buts pour
les icaunais et pour le département
ça veut dire que vous pensez qu'il faut
changer de tête à la
donc à la tête du conseil départemental
de l'yonne pour lui donner plus d'allant
et on pense notamment à vous on a
beaucoup dit que vous seriez
éventuellement candidat à la présidence
du conseil départemental
est-ce que ce soir c'est le cas oui je
suis candidat à la présidence du conseil
départemental je vous le confirme vous
savez c'est pas une lubie ou une
gloriole
lorsqu'il a fallu désigner un président
pour reprendre le bailleur social
domanys en grande difficulté
personne ne voulait y aller bien moi
j'ai pris mes responsabilités je me suis
porté candidat est bien dans un esprit
justement de service eh bien je suis
dans ce même état d'esprit et l'idée
c'est surtout de bâtir une équipe un
collectif avec des femmes et des hommes
de talent alliant à la fois justement
l'expérience mais également un regard
neuf et je peux vous dire que les défis
sont sont là ils sont de taille 1 parce
qu'on sait que les dotations sont en
baisse que c'est pas évident et pour
autant les attentes sont très fortes
donc vous à me débiner et donc je
souhaite vraiment que nous mettions en
place une équipe qui soit forte
cohérente qui puisse peser aussi dans
les arbitrages dans les négociations
avec l'état avec la bourgogne vous savez
le contrat de plan état région
il ya bien des projets malheureusement
que dans l'yonne on va pas pouvoir
financer qui n'ont pas été rendus
éligibles
donc tout ça interroge et donc je pense
qu'il faut donner un poids accru au
conseil des partenaires alain vous
n'ignorez pas que andré villiers s'était
déjà déclaré candidat à la présidence à
sa propre succession avant le premier
tour est ce que ça veut dire que vous
vous êtes entendu avec lui ou est ce
qu'il y aura deux candidats pour
présider ce département mais ce qu'il
est il est normal et naturel que dans
une famille politique la droite et le
centre
il puisse y avoir un débat sur le style
qui doit incarner la présidence sur les
objectifs concrets
vous savez un l'idée c'est d'aller
bouger les lignes effectivement le but
c'est de faire remonter un peu le
département de l'yonne dans dans le haut
du tableau
1 parce que vous savez nous on a là gît
à auxerre qui est en ligue 2 on en
revient qui monte en ligue 1 et dans le
département de l'yonne on l'a vu un peu
trop souvent dans les bas de tableau
dans les classements
sur les départements et nous on a envie
de faire bouger ça on a envie d'être
très volontariste parce qu'encore une
fois il ya une attente et un cri de
désespoir qui a été émis par par
l'électorat au premier tour 1 il faut il
faut il faut voir que au soir du premier
tour personnes faisaient les malins
donc maintenant maintenant il s'agit pas
de faire comme si rien ne s'était passé
maintenant il faut être au rendez vous
des résultats et ça ben voila je propose
de le bâtir avec mes collègues et j'en
parlerai que tous les collègues
conseillers départementaux naturellement
dès demain matin justement c'est ce
qu'on allait vous demandez encore deux
petites questions est ce que vous avez
fait vos compte justement pour vous
lancer dans à l'assaut de la présidence
du conseil départemental est ce que vous
observez que vous avez beaucoup d'allant
ce non mais attendez moi je suis pas à
faire des comptes d'apothicaire là on a
besoin j'irai de lancer un projet de
monter l'équipe qui va avec
on est là dedans attendez les comptes
d'apothicaire où les les petits calculs
politiciens sur les petit réchaud comme
disait le général de gaulle c'est fini
c'est mort les français n'en veulent
plus donc maintenant je n'irai nulle
d'étendre à enrichir le pont d'alcool
pardon jean baptiste lully déchire le
pont d'arcole est allé aux résultats oui
mes calculs ou pas 2010 est le cumul des
mandats vous obligera à choisir si vous
devenez président du conseil
départemental
vous avez peut-être un peu vite en
musique là parce que vous savez que la
droite et le centre annoncé qu' il
souhaitait revenir sur cette
interdiction parce que honnêtement gars
voir un mandat local et un mandat
national c'est la meilleure façon garder
les pieds sur terre et parfois il y en a
qui a à paris pète un peu les plombs
parce qu'ils ont peut-être plus les
pieds sur terre
donc je peux vous dire que justement de
ce point de vue là concilier ses deux
mandats
eh bien je pense que c'est la façon
d'être entendu de façon efficace par
l'état à paris et puis d'agir ici
localement
là encore avec une efficacité accrue
merci jean baptiste lemoyne on a bien
entendu votre message
donc vous voulez une équipe pour l'yonne
et vous souhaitez être donc le capitaine
de cette équipe monte en régime tour
attendu avec impatience je dis ça c'est
moins qu'on puisse dire